well first of all happy Halloween happy
Halloween I have to know have you ever
had a crazy costume you've worn
no
nothing crazy no no I can't see a person
really you guys I dressed up as Carmen
Electra nice and my sister uh was uh oh
what's it was a guy Fury yeah we're on
this guy here in Carmen Electra kind of
around like Charlie something cool come
on no I'm that guy listen I have a
cultural bias in in the UK only children
celebrating Halloween and so I've never
been able to liberate myself of that
perspective and so rarely when I go to a
costume party I will just go in my
regular clothes and when people ask me
what I'm dressed up as I say the only
adult in the room
worries
no it doesn't play nobody likes it no he
has a Ruder version as well I get it I
get it though congratulations on this
series I absolutely loved it and I love
the fact that it's a series because you
let the story breathe and I understand
you read this book seven years ago it
took three years to make this happen
um as the producer is this series
everything you wanted
you know it's so funny I I listened to a
long interview with Woody Allen uh 20
years 15 years ago and he was talking
about his how he defines success being
as close to the original aspiration the
end result being as close to the
original sort of the Genesis idea as
possible because there's always just
Untold obstacles and challenges and
and it's hard you know to to fulfill a
singular Creative Vision so the short
answer is no but I think we learned a
lot from the first season I think that
hopefully if we go back again we won't
have quite as many obstacles in our way
and you know it's always a process right
that's the beauty of long form
storytelling if done well is you you
learn what works and you learn what's
good and then you capitalize on that so
that's my hope if we're lucky enough to
go back season two we'll do more of the
magic yeah less of the stuff that you
know we didn't feel really resonated
that's a great idea and from producer to
the main character Lynn the fact that
you read the book you made the series
and now it's out there what does Lynn
represent to you now
that's an interesting question I mean he
for me it was a vehicle to explore
everything that I'm interested in life I
read shantaram and it was a much more
sophisticated exploration of a lot of
the things that I was sort of exploring
in my own life which is why I got so
excited Greg is an extraordinary thinker
you know the author and so
I don't know how to answer that question
other than a vehicle to you know a
really wonderful opportunity within that
character for me to explore the things
I'm most excited about in life
you're so funny I loved you in this
character oh you're so good and the
chemistry between you and Charlie and
Prabhu and Linda Babu like it's just so
it's like the Thelma the Louise I think
you guys need to do some other kind of
yeah that's great
spin-off spin-off
do you remember the first conversation
with Charlie when you first met him was
that instant for you guys we were
reminiscing earlier today uh now look I
met Charlie across like a weird sort of
man-made lake Yeah in our Bangkok
quarantine and he was like this big on
the back of me like hey man we're gonna
work together for six months yeah that
was like it was just sort of like he was
far away yeah and I just saw him drawing
his clothes uh on on the yeah so I was
like this guy likes an orange hoodie
but I did wear the same arms every day
fluorescent orange fluorescence
wasn't there a night where he had a few
drinks and you guys were doing
Shakespeare and someone was putting
someone to bed we weren't doing
Shakespearean I don't know if you were
actually doing Shakespeare sorry
what happened
I did we drank for 16 hours straight and
then I carried you to bed very gently
you know
fixed the the you know he's got the hair
out of your eyes and kissed your
forehead so you know there was some
bombs and and somebody recorded that and
then there's a video of the next day
where's the video no you have to give me
the video no I cannot come on he's made
me sign an end please there's no NBA but
now I realized I was remiss please don't
ever show that video to anyone I've seen
it I've seen it
the next morning
yeah man I was puking the whole thing
the whole night do you remember that day
on here yeah I wasn't on sad but I said
the video oh my gosh you know and the
fact that you guys shot this in India
and other places Thailand Australia but
for you to be in India I the first thing
I think about is chaos how was it on set
this must have been a challenge it was K
I mean it that's the beauty of India you
can't control it and I think you know
being in in streets that you can't close
down and not being in control of
whatever happens and whoever is in the
show is pretty exciting like there was a
scene where Charlie just all of a sudden
disappeared and ended back and he's on a
motorbike that just sort of drove past
and then he comes back running I'm
holding children's hands that are not
supposed to be in the scene I don't know
for me India was a very very special
Adventure but then we didn't go back to
India so we went to Thailand and then
that was a lot more controlled in terms
of environment because we've had close
heads and
um extras that were tested and they were
supposed to be here and um I don't know
there's a pro pro income
you've been there like how many times
four or five times I guess yeah
something like that four times I think
you know when you go to India or even
Africa is changes you spiritually I
think there's always that experience I
don't know if you've had it but like
um yeah you were born you were born in
India yeah I didn't know that that's
awesome I've been back to India every
year of my life bar the two covered
years it was really good and like when
we were filming it in filming shantaram
yeah which we didn't do in India it was
like it was weird how I was like
being in India but it was the only like
year that I didn't actually go to India
and I actually went recently to Bombay a
couple of months ago and I was like it
was very weird to sort of go around the
streets and be like oh God this is what
this is this is what we were doing it
was weirdly nostalgic in a very sort of
fictional sense but yeah no so you would
make a great tour guide then no not
known
I was born there and then literally as
as soon as I could biologically get on a
plane it was shipped to Trinidad and
Tobago
is there any experience you had that you
remember the most about India
I mean dengue fever
no I listen I I went to India for the
first time
um for a month to just go and explore
you know I I knew or was hopeful that
this was gonna go and I went to India
and and just had a hotel book for one
night
um with my partner and we just wanted to
go and see where see what India wanted
to show us in that month in India was
pretty pretty Sensational particularly I
spent a week in Varanasi on the banks of
the river Ganges with um uh with a
collection of sadhu holy men that it was
sat in silence for a week and smoked
um you know which was extraordinary in
science one once a day the sadhu would
get very serious and I didn't know if
you spoke English or not we literally
just communed in silence you know and
then he would say once a day he would
say
problem
go away very fast no problem
sit smoke be with God
and I realized he spoke perfect English
but what else are you going to say other
than said smoke be with God
good life motto you know so that was
really extraordinary it's going to sit
with those men yeah and Elektra you
to a dark place with your character and
you have a Canadian connect
but what did you learn about yourself
going through that process and making
Lisa come alive I think what was most
daunting wasn't necessarily at least as
a character per se it was being away for
eight nine months and we were in a lot
of quarantine and a lot of uh Solitude
and uh facing myself for the first time
in my entire life I've always been been
moving around traveling different places
been with my identical twin sister and
this was the first time where I just sat
with myself and I think we all did in
many different ways and that was that
was really then that really informed
Lisa as well I got time to spend with
her in my head too so that was that was
really amazing it was scary but it was
really really amazing and finally
because the show's out there now what do
you want viewers to get out of this
I want them to be entertained yeah yeah
first and foremost it's a TV show enjoy
it untouched
relationships of the people in the shop
and I think you know there's there's a
lot of people that haven't had the
opportunity to go to India to see that
culture to get a flavor of it and
although I shouldn't said we weren't
able because of covet to shoot in India
I think that there is you know there is
a little bit of an experience to be had
of a different culture and a different
place and the show set in the 80s so
there's that sort of different time you
know
fresh
congratulations to all of you thank you
so much